Now this brings us to the next area of study in motivation in the workplace,
and that is intrinsic motivation. An intrinsic motivation comes from within the
person, and it includes four elements. First we have challenge, and that is how
much you enjoy the thrill and excitement of challenges. The second is
enjoyment. And that is how much pleasure you receive from the process of doing
a task. Mastery is our next term. And this is whether you gain a sense of
accomplishment and pride in doing a difficult task. And lastly, we have
autonomy, and this is whether you believe you are free to determine much of
what you do, and how you do it. So intrinsic motivation comes from within the
person. And we have four ways in which we discuss this.